Розкажіть будь ласка що ми сьогодні вам
привезли перше це ми бачимо дизельний
генератори дуже необхідна річ в полях
крім генераторів
майже немає інших
джерел живлення і
генератори працюють постійно
24 на 7 це наше все і світло і десь
обігрів
без генераторів було би сліпі нічого не
чули і тому подібне так сказати
заходить для аеророзвідки генератора
кожен політ це Дрон або БПЛА Він же ж
більшість акумуляторних Їх потрібно
заряджати Дрон якщо сів Наприклад тут же
маю так само
розповсюджений Дрон він сів поміняв
акумулятори зразу запускаєш його
потрібно заряджати просто постійно
якщо даже більше літачок теж на ньому є
акумулятор Даже якщо ДВС над двигун у
нього є акумулятор ти би трансляцію тебе
потрібно по трансляцію 24/7 так само ти
ж маєш десь брати живлення скільки ти
повербанки скільки не наберешся а Даже
якщо би був Power bank тобі його
потрібно десь заряджати і
[музика]
Ну ти ж не будеш їздити не знаю там до
Києва щоб його Зарядити і той в Києві на
постійно я живлення А нам потрібно
постійно Ну ми працюємо 24/7
Я вже повторювався наші хлопці В окопах
потребують тому що це ми очі не тільки
піхоти А перед в цьому артилерії
артилерія без нас немає цілі Ми даємо
цілі артилерія працює чим більше
артилерія працюють тим легше наше піхоті
і ближче до нашої Перемоги ми от скільки
не їздили ми передавали ці сторінки але
в основному по одній штуці і люди були
якби дуже раді навіть одному стерлізу
тут цілих п'ять там де від нуля до 20 км
нема жодного зв'язку нема мобільного
зв'язку нема електрики
радіостанції
наш вороги вміють їх прослуховувати
вміють їх глушити повністю подивитись
скупчення радіостанції Може ти ще й
вдарити а стерлінк его важко
відслідкувати він один а небагато
Це інтернет через інтернет
можна передати і координати і зв'язок із
причому це шифрований зв'язок крім
військової цілі це іще її можливість
Відправити повідомлення там дружині
матері дітям з тим хто там на передові
Та тут дуже важливо Ну то есть наприклад
даже стало АТО 14-й 16-й рік люди були
без зв'язку місяцями і жінки навіть не
знали зараз там раз хотя би на тиждень
людини є можливість там знаєте там десь
або біля штабу або біля себе хотя би
відправити повідомлення Це теж дуже
важливо Це психологічна Ми ж ві- воюєм
не тільки зброю чи психологічно Тому
стерлінк це дуже важлива чим більше їх
будем ближче ми будемо до перемоги
я
нічого в історії про обмороження от
Наскільки нам взагалі це ну часто і
наскільки вони потрібні Я особисто не
зустрічав обмороження Але можу сказати
що були моменти коли було дуже холодно і
була відчуття Так що ти прямо втратиш
зараз якісь пальці або кінцівки довгий
час майже статична тому що ти ж не будеш
бігати перед там снайпером або просто ти
в тебе нема місця коп маленький ти маєш
мінімально рухатись тому що твій рух
тебе де маскує
і
зігрітися нема можливості Ти ж не підеш
О я замерз піду десь зігріюсь вогнища
там теж не можеш розігріти хімічна
горілка дуже допомагає вона ще
така що неодноразово перейти і коли
можеш на базі
перезарядити так як в кипятку
вона повторна може працювати І вона дуже
маленька легка мобільна Тобто ти її коли
тобі холодно дістав А знаєш годин на 4-5
прям хочу сказати прямо такі враження що
ти
[музика]
зимою але на тебе такий Лучик сонця і ну
реально допомагає особливо там де
потрібні
[музика]
як аеророзвідник це нам потрібно з
маніпулятором працювати пальці І коли ти
Пальців не чуєш а тут горілка А вона
тебе зігріла і ти можеш продовжувати
далі працювати
і розкажіть що будь ласка я не знаю чи є
у вас там час чи можливість взагалі
зайти в Тік то там мем - це колеса Я
думаю що ви бачили от але якщо серйозно
наскільки взагалі от колесо потрібні
колеса потрібні тому що багато
вантажівок
[музика]
На жаль вже зі старою резиною і
болото - это Брут болото не проходимі
десь такі тропи і дороги Це 99% де
їздять військова техніка а навіть ще й
по цій дорозі могли приїхати багато
техніки і чесно кажучи застревали і
КРАЗи застрягали і 9 в деяких місцях і
танки не могли приїхати тому
резина нова для під болота Брут Та ну
дуже особливо зараз буде трошки опір і
ці дороги болота це це дуже
яскраво звучить это якісь болото в
квадраті тому що без
Нової резини просто далеко не поїдеш
хочуть у тебя будет трьохосівий КРАЗ без
резини ти не поїдеш тому що
вона Такий бруд наліпає на колеса І ти
вже нікуди не їдеш Ти як стоїш на місці
І Колеса крутяться А якщо добре резина
Ну тут такі широкий профіль
так що вона дуже допоможе нащо вам цілу
вантажів
я хочу сказати дві Та мало нами
будь-які комплекси це не просто Дрон або
літачок это я как эророзвідник вам
розповім це багато ще обладнання причому
крім там антени командного пункту систем
керування потім запасних частин
так літачок генератор паливо акумулятори
і Ще іще ж не забувайте що це не одна
особа працює там ну в різних екіпажах
різних людей може до 10 бути І у кожного
є ще і свої речі
набої гранати
аптечки
розгрузки і тепло одяг зараз холодно у
кожного там має бути термобілизна
запасний одяг на випадок якщо промокнеш
і це ну Я вам просто це назвав А це
уявився в там 10-кратному розмірі більше
тобто вантажівки даже мало вантажівки
кілька вантажівок і така ще й
повнопривідна вантажівка це обов'язково
отам лучше не повна приводна вантажівка
вона застрягне вперше
калюжі
і ще крім цього ще
обладнання
частіше буває ще й на причепах і цей
причепи ще потрібно тягнути ти ж добре
якщо бичок якийсь знаєте там хамбі був
на якому там
можеш тягнути і броньований но
вантажівка Це мінімум мінімум що
потрібно